the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
got much more than one request to do
some stuff on nuclear materials and I
think it's just about the right time you
guys know enough about radiation and
driving would matter and everything and
stopping power with prop sections after
excess of nuclear materials and
radiation damage this is my whole field
so happy to come talk to you guys about
this and show you why can you finish
because it all of yours it starts out
this this slide kind of gets on to it it
starts off with the single atom atomic
defects that make up the basic building
blocks of damage and ends up with things
that break in nuclear reactors under
radiation and so to understand the whole
thing you've got to know everything from
the single atoms on the sort of
femtosecond scale all the way up to the
engineering scale where things evolve
over years or even decades so I'll be
talking first probably today we're gonna
go over a material science primer so who
here's how many courses in material
science no one that's good because I'm
assuming that there's a let's see no one
knows anything here I know there's a
couple material scientists in the class
and I apologize ahead of time if it's a
bit of a review but we'll be going
mostly through what are materials and
what are the defects that change their
material properties and how do they
behave that'll take us through about
today so then tomorrow we can see how
radiation causes those defects and
actually changes material properties so
there's a whole laundry list of
different ways that materials fail and
most folks are concerned with all of
these everyone everything from simple
overload which means you stress
something too much and it just breaks to
all the different forms of corrosion
that's a whole field in itself and then
there's the things that just we have to
worry about because there are only
activated with radiation damage and in
this case this isn't quite ionization by
radiation but it's actual radiation
slamming into nuclei and moving atoms
out of their place and we've got one
figure that we had recently in a paper
that sums up the entire multi scale
picture of radiation damage from the
femtosecond
to let's say the mega second scale or i
think it's more than that maybe Giga
second would be the right word for that
and all the way down from the angstrom
to the meters
scale and I want to pine WA walk you
through sort of a lens scale by lens
scale depiction of radiation damage it
all starts with knocking atoms out of
place we've mentioned this a little bit
when we talked about nuclear stopping
power and this is where it actually
comes into play sometimes an incoming
Neutron or photon or ion can displace an
atom from its original site and we call
that a physical that's a displacement
and then that atom comes off with quite
a bit of kinetic energy and can knock
into a whole bunch of other atoms now
this loss of the solid crystalline
structure you can't really tell what the
original structure looked like right it
actually comprises a very small
localized zone of melting called the
thermal spike if you think about all
these atoms are vibrating at fractions
of an AV at thermal energies like the
thermal neutrons we talked about in the
reactor then you hit them with an MeV
neutron they might transfer a hundred ke
v of energy and a bunch of these atoms
will then be moving about at let's say a
few hundred Evie that's way beyond
liquid temperature so actually it's it's
been theorized that there's a little
pocket of atoms around three to five
nanometers wide that reaches like ten
thousand Kelvin for a very very short
amount of time less than a picosecond
because almost instantly those atoms
knock into the ones around them and this
is how the process of heat transfer
occurs and so very quickly you get
what's called the quench where most of
those atoms very quickly knock into
other ones slowing down finding their
equilibrium positions again but not
everyone you can see there's a few
places where the atoms are still out of
their original location and it's those
residual defects that actually comprise
radiation damage and as those defects
build up they start to move they can
diffuse they can be transported
ballistically by more radiation damage
they can move by all sorts of different
mechanisms and eventually find each
other forming what's called clusters so
a bunch of those missing atoms could
find each other and make a hole which we
call a void a bunch of the extra atoms
shoved in between the other ones can
form things called interstitial
clusters we say interstitial because
it's like in the space in between where
you'd normally find some atoms so let's
say you had a whole bunch of those
missing atoms come together forming a
void this is an actual transmission
electron microscope or TEM image of a
void pockets of vacuum in materials no
does anything interesting about its
shape it's rounded but what's the most
striking to me is it isn't actually
round so you would expect a void or a
bubble to be kind of spherical right
that's the minimum energy configuration
of most things not so when you have a
little pocket of vacuum
it's where crystallinity comes into play
and these voids can end up forming super
structures what kind of what curious
thing do you notice here for this whole
ensemble of voids yeah they are all in
the same direction kind of funny that's
that's definitely not an accident right
it's not like they're randomly aligned
there's a reason for this that will go
into in a couple slides yeah the size
scale I think these are on the order of
20 nanometers or so yeah I crop these
images just to get points across let's
see if it says in the other one not
quite yeah but these voids can get
upwards of tens of nanometers as
smallest single atoms yeah this is the
accumulation of radiation defects into
what's called voids yeah don't worry
we'll go over in more detail again and
if you get little pockets of vacuum in
your material where you yeah you're not
creating or destroying mass you're just
moving it so those voids where that mass
was has to go somewhere else and you
actually get things that swell in the
reactor on their own they don't change
mass but they change volume they just
kind of puff up like Swiss cheese
sometimes upwards of twenty or thirty
percent changes in diameter and length
for some tubing now if you're depending
on these fuel rods being a certain space
apart in a reactor and they start to
swell squeezing out the coolant you lose
the ability to cool the reactor
because then how can you get water
around something where the tubes are
then swell together there's lots of
other bad things that can happen which
we'll get into and so then that's the
origin of void swelling from single
missing atoms called vacancies they can
cluster into voids which then caused
physical dimensional changes of
materials on the scale of centimeters to
meters and that's why we say it's this
full multi scale picture of radiation
damage but to understand what is damage
you have to know what is an undamaged
structure to begin with so it doesn't
make sense to say how does a structure
change if you don't know how it behaves
so I want to give a very quick primer to
material science and apologies to any
material scientists in the room because
this is gonna seem really basic but this
is a very quick intro to this whole
field I want to go over quickly what is
a crystalline solid and perfectly
undamaged material would be a set of
atoms lined up in a very regular lattice
in a regular array where you move over a
certain distance and you find another
atom and this extends forever and ever
and ever all the way out to when you
reach the free surface and so this what
we would call an undamaged material a
pristine perfect single crystal by
crystal I mean an arrangement of atoms
in a certain direction so notice here
all the atoms are lined up in let's say
some cubic XYZ way that's what we would
call one crystal or one green you'll
hear this you'll hear both of those and
you'll notice also that the arrangement
of the atoms tends to determine what the
physical objects look like or we like to
say that for that was it formed follows
structure in material science so for
materials like pyrite which follows a
simple cubic structure that's the
crystals you pull out of the ground they
mimic their atomic configurations in
physical centimeter sized space for gold
atoms they adopt a slightly different
structure it's still cubic but there's
atoms shoved into the cube faces so what
we call a face centered cubic or FCC and
you start to see Cube looking structures
all over single crystals of gold another
one gypsum it's got a very different
a structure called monoclinic where none
of the sides of this parallelogram are
the same and there's some funny angles
but if you look at the arrangement of
the atoms and the actual crystals a bit
of gypsum that grow you sees a striking
similarity which I find pretty neat I
also want to mention what is the absence
of structure and material science we
call that something that's amorphous
amorphous means without form so for
example crystal and indium phosphide
would have this regular structure like
this you move over a certain distance
you see another green atom and so on and
so on and so on in an amorphous material
it can still be a solid but there's no
fixed distance between any certain types
of atoms and radiation can cause a lot
of this amorphous a ssin by knocking the
atoms about and having them freeze in
random configurations this is one of the
ways that radiation damage can in
brittle materials because well we'll get
into that so now let's talk about the
defects that can be created in a perfect
crystal the simplest ones we call point
defects or zero dimensional because
they're just single atoms out of place
you can have what's called a vacancy
where if you had let's say a face
centered cubic lattice of atoms or you
have atoms on every Q corner and every
face if you just pull one out somewhere
we refer to that as a vacancy a missing
atom it had to go somewhere though and
we'll get to where it is in just a sec
so it might be kind of hard to
conceptualize how do we know that there
are missing atoms in all these little
cubes or lattices we do have direct
evidence they're what's called quenching
studies where you can measure the
resistance or resistivity of a piece of
material after heating it to a certain
temperature because it turns out that
the hotter you make something the more
of those vacancies just naturally occur
you won't actually ever find an
absolutely perfect single crystal
anywhere in nature unless you go to 0
Kelvin for infinite time and the atoms
arrange themselves thusly there's always
some amount of atomic vibration going on
and there's actually some thermodynamic
energy gain to having a few defects in
your structure and that game
say that number of defects increases
with increasing temperature once you get
to the melting point of a material like
right before something melts you can
have up to one in 10,000 atoms just
missing moved somewhere else we call
that the thermal equilibrium vacancy
concentration and we can measure that
using these resistivity measurements
where you heat materials up to higher
and higher temperatures cool them down
suddenly and like liquid nitrogen or
liquid helium and measure the change in
resistivity the more defects there are
the harder it is for electrons to flow
through and the only thing that can
really be responsible there in a single
element would be vacancies so we do know
that these really exist
they can also cluster up it turns out
that every time you have a vacancy in a
material the other atoms move in a
little bit towards it relaxing the
pressure they feel from the atoms nearby
and one way for a whole bunch of
vacancies to lower the stress of the
whole atomic configuration is to cluster
together so if you have a whole bunch of
vacancies they may not allow as much
stress accommodation as if they were
separate when they're together now you
might ask what happened to the original
atoms you can't just take atoms away and
then go nowhere because you can't just
destroy matter right unless you turn it
into energy which is what we do in
nuclear engineering so in the material
science world they end up as what's
called interstitials where you know you
have a vacancy created from somewhere
that knocks that atom out and it gets
stuck in the next biggest space between
some other atoms and we refer to those
as interstitials and those can cluster
up to to reduce their total stress in
the lattice they can cluster up into
what's called split dumbbell
interstitials instead of having one
extra atom shoved in here you might
rearrange a couple so there's two atoms
in the center of a cube instead of one
and that tends to be a lower energy or a
more stable configuration so let's look
a little bit at the energetics of these
point defects because understanding how
they move and why will tell us a lot
about how radiation damage happens so it
turns out that interstitials are very
hard to make
it's really hard to shove an atom where
it doesn't want to be but once you get
it there it moves very easily let's draw
a quick simple cubic lattice to do a
little thought experiment and explore
why that might be let's say I want to
shove an interstitial atom in here
between these other atoms well their
electron clouds are going to repel and
it's going to push all the nearby atoms
away by just a little bit and these ones
might push the other atoms away by just
a little bit stretching out the lattice
or adding some compressive stress
wherever that interstitial is but then
how would it move what's the biggest
barrier it has to overcome to get to the
next adjacent location well which
direction would it go would it go this
way probably not there's an atom in the
way so it's gonna find the path of least
resistance to try to get over here
because like we've talked about before
all atoms are always in motion vibrating
some of them will be energetic enough to
squeeze through these two atoms and get
over to the next site and that turns out
to be a pretty easy process we can look
at the energy required for an
interstitial to move we notice it's
really small fractions of an electron
volt whereas creating them takes 2 or 3
electron volts in an atomic land that's
a very high energy penalty now let's
look at vacancies they're quite the
opposite
they're rather easy to make but they're
very hard to move compared to
interstitials notice that the energy of
movement is about the same as the energy
of formation for vacancies to take an
atom outer - pluck it out you have to
break every bond between nearby atoms so
you actually have to put energy in to
break those bonds and then remove the
atom somewhere else now these things are
usually made in pairs so if you think
about how much energy would it take to
cause a single radiation damage event
where you have one vacancy which let's
say
would have been right here and one
interstitial it takes the sum of these
two energies usually about four electron
volts that's not something that tends to
happen chemically or from stress or from
something like that but radiation coming
in with hundreds of kV or even MeV
neutrons anything's on the table because
it's high enough energy so it would take
about three or four evey to make a pair
of a vacancy and an interstitial if you
just add these two up it comes usually
to about three or four evey or electron
volts and that's a very difficult thing
to do in sort of chemical world where
you know reactions might proceed with
fractions of an electron volt but when
you have MeV neutrons coming in they can
do whatever they want
well they deal what they'll do whatever
they will so someone actually asked me
yesterday what sort of materials can you
put in the way of neutrons to stop them
from doing damage and the answer is
pretty much nothing they test neutrons
tend to travel about 10 centimeters even
in things like steel or water and
they're gonna hit what they're gonna hit
there's not much you can do but put more
things in the way and we can only get to
a certain density with regular matter I
think osmium has upwards of like 22
grams per cubic centimeter density
that's not enough to stop neutrons even
over a considerable distance unless you
had like liquid neutrons star that you
could pack nuclei in and away higher
number density not much you can do so
I'm moving up in the dimensions there's
another type of defect called a
dislocation where it's actually
energetically favorable to slide an
extra half plane of atoms in between two
sets in here in the crystal lattice
creating a sort of bulged out structure
like you see right here and dislocations
are one of the most important defects in
material science and radiation damage
there what I like to call the agents of
plasticity
if you deform a material enough that it
doesn't just spring back then low most
likely you were creating and moving
dislocations in the material do you
think about a couple of diff
ways to cause deformation let's bring
our perfect lattice back without all
these extra notations if you want to
slide or shear two planes of atoms
across and they're all bonded to each
other
what do you physically have to do how
can you get these atoms to slide across
each other what what sort of energy do
you have to put into it yeah yep because
all these atoms are bonded to each other
if you want them to move you have to
break every bond on that plane that's a
lot of atomic bonds to break and it's
extremely unlikely that that would
happen in fact if you broke an entire
plane of bonds in some material like
this what would you physically do to it
it snap it in half
that would be fracture so if you broke
every bond down this plane you would
then have two pieces of this fuel rod
that's usually a pretty high-energy
thing to try to do so instead if you
shove an extra half plane of atoms in
there and the bonds are kind of funny
like so right at that extra half plane
location then what you can actually do
is break one let's say you break this
one form the next one then break this
one and form the next one and for a few
atoms to move over you only have to
break a line of bonds not a plane so
it's much less energy-intensive to get a
dislocation to move than to just break
something in half now you might ask well
then why do things actually break
whether or not things deform or break is
a balance between this process which we
call slip and breaking an entire plane
of atoms which we call fracture so this
one's called slip
the other mode is fracture
we would rather materials to form in
systems like reactors by slip just
moving a little bit than just breaking
all together
unfortunately when enough radiation hits
materials you can fracture things in a
brittle manner and we'll see what
happens then there's a couple kinds of
dislocations one of them is called a
screw dislocation so imagine you had a
whole bunch of sheets of atoms and you
made a cut halfway through that sheet
and then moved every plane up by one
position you then got what's called a
screw dislocation kind of a spiral
parking-garage of atoms surrounding that
core right there
you can also have what's called an edge
dislocation which is like the one I've
got here on the board right here where
you just have an extra half plane of
atoms shoved in right there so there's
two types and they move in two different
ways the edge dislocation may behaves
like you may physically expect if you
kind of push like this on two planes of
atoms it moves in the direction you push
it screw dislocations are kind of screwy
if you push like this it moves
perpendicular not gonna get into why but
just remember screw dislocations are
fairly screwy in the way that they
behave not quite intuitive well that's
okay we don't have to worry about those
and the way that they actually move like
we showed right here is by what's called
glide or slip where dislocations can
slide just by one plane of atoms or one
atomic position in a mechanism that
looks something like this whereas that
dislocation moves you only have to break
a line of bonds and then reform a line
of bonds which is a much easier process
than breaking an entire plane at once
it's like you have to break the square
root of the same number of bonds when a
skip head from some of that there's one
other mechanism of dislocation movement
that's important to us in radiation
damage and that's called climb this is
when you start to think about what
happens if you have a dislocation which
will give this symbol right here
and you also have a vacancy let's say
created by radiation damage if that
vacancy can move it's going to find the
most stressed-out part of this lattice
most likely the vacancy will move here
in other words the atom will move over
there leaving this vacancy over there
it's kind of funny to think like what
does it mean that a vacancy moves has
anyone ever done anything with
semiconductors and talked about electron
and hole movement okay yeah so what does
it really mean for a hole to move right
it's a holes not a thing a vacancy is
also not a thing it's an absence of an
atom but here we can say that the
vacancy moves in this direction when the
corresponding atom moves in the exact
opposite direction and then what you've
actually done is moved your dislocation
up instead of moving in the slip
direction you've now moved it in a
perpendicular direction this is usually
not possible without things like
radiation damage or very high
temperature and then to make things even
crazier you can also have what's called
loops of dislocations some videos of
which I'll actually get to show you you
can have a dislocation that has part
edge character part screw character if
you look at how the atoms are arranged
here you're looking from sort of the top
down you can see that there's an extra
half plane of these white atoms shoved
in in the black ones and this right here
would be a completely edge dislocation
you can have a gradual transition or
about ninety degrees later it looks like
a spiral and that's a screw dislocation
and the net effect of that is when you
push in this direction on an edge
dislocation it moves that way when you
push this direction on a screw
dislocation it moves that way so when
you stress out a dislocation loop it
just grows you're not actually creating
or destroying matter but what you're
doing is causing this small loop of
extra half plane of atoms to grow
further and further until it actually
reaches some obstacle or the outside of
a crystal and these dislocations can
actually feel the force from each other
if I draw a clean one because I think
it'll be easier to see if I draw a small
lattice of atoms here and then a
dislocation core right there let's say
that's our dislocation core this region
of space right here is compressively
stressed there's more atoms in that
space than there want to be and so it's
kind of crammed in there
well this region right here is in what's
called tensile stress there's almost
some space like right here where there's
notice to few atoms and they kind of
want there to be more and these
dislocations can feel neighboring stress
fields let's say there was another one
right over here that had its own
compressive stress field they'll
actually repel each other because you
don't want to add even more compressive
stress to anywhere in this group of
atoms so they'll actually repel each
other to the point where if you get two
dislocations too close to each other
they'll uh they'll what's called pileup
or they'll refuse to move a bit so I
want to show you some videos we can
actually see these dislocations in this
one you see that faint line right there
originating from this area that's
actually a dislocation loop under stress
and that's actually growing so what
you're seeing here is an image of
electrons passing through material and
looking at regions of differing contrast
so wherever there's more atoms or fewer
atoms it looks darker or lighter and
that can tell you what sort of defects
there are you guys all see that faint
line right there
notice how the loop just growing it's
not like you're moving a line but you're
literally growing the line out of what
looks like nothing there's other one
what we call a a Frank Reed source it's
a source of dislocation loop so what
you're seeing here each of these lines
is a single dislocation and then right
there you see that loop suddenly form
let's let's show you that one again I'll
point on where to look by stressing out
materials you can actually create
additional dislocation loops
around here and there it is you guys see
that one yeah out of what looks like
nothing but is actually just a couple of
atomic defects you can create a
dislocation loop and allow more plastic
deformation to take place which i think
is awesome
see this one another dislocation source
in germanium it's a little easier to see
also because it's making this sort of
spiral set of dislocations a little
slower so you can track its motion a
little easier notice how they all kind
of line up on certain atomic planes yeah
the topology will change let's say if it
hits another optical or another
dislocation yeah they can slam into each
other and change topology all sorts of
things yeah that's a subject for a whole
nother class I'd say I want to skip
ahead to the pileup because I think this
kind of gets the point across but
there's actually we can see direct
evidence that dislocations feel each
other's stress fields when you get
enough of them lined up they won't
overlap they actually push each other in
a kind of dislocation traffic jam
because that what's happening on the
atomic level is they feel each other
stress fields there might be a source of
dislocations further away but when they
get too close to each other it literally
is a dislocation traffic jam I mean if
you try and hit the car in front of you
the repulsion of the electrons between
your and their bumper will prevent the
cars from getting a certain distance
closer to each other same kind of thing
here
moving on to grain boundaries a
two-dimensional defect anytime you have
a perfect crystal of atoms that meets
another perfect crystal at a different
orientation where the atoms are arranged
in a different direction you end up with
a boundary between them that we refer to
as a grain boundary so you can actually
see this is a direct physical image of
atoms of two different crystals meaning
at the grain boundary again taken in the
transmission electron microscope so for
those who didn't know yes we can see
individual atoms and the defect
between them I definitely didn't know
that in high school they didn't even
mention that whatsoever did you guys
ever seen images like this anyone yes
raise your hand just one okay so yeah
it's important for you guys to know that
we can have direct evidence for all this
blackboard stuff because you can see
atoms in the transmission electron
microscope and see what happens when the
two of them meet you see this kind of
regular structure of empty space where
this grain boundary meets right you can
actually model it as a line of 1d
dislocations because you take a line of
1d lines you end up with a 2d boundary
which you can see very clearly here it's
almost like there's an extra half plane
right there another one there another
one there and another one there and we
call that a tilt grain boundary grain
boundaries are nice in that they can
accommodate lots of these little zero
dimensional defects moving to them
without getting destroyed so grain
boundaries are one of those ways that
radiation damage can be removed and
that's one of the reasons why most small
grain materials are really nano grain
materials are more resistant to
radiation damage than large grain ones
because they act as what's called sinks
or destroyers of radiation damage
there's another kind of 2d defect called
a twin where you can actually get a
little chunk of atoms sort of switch
orientation and you can see these very
clearly in again TEM micrographs and the
evidence actually that the twin actually
is a different physical arrangement of
atoms even though you can't see the
atoms in this little bar in this little
band right there look at the way the
dislocations line up those dislocations
tend to line up in energetically
favorable directions and in this screen
they're all this way and in the twin
they're all lined up like that and then
finally there's the most intuitive
defect inclusions a 3d piece of some
other material inside what would
otherwise be a pure material this one I
actually pulled out of the rotor that
powers the Alka Tour fusion reactor I
was asked to do some analysis to find
out is the structure
of that road are changing because
General Electric who was ensuring this
rotor said we don't want to insure it
anymore thanks for the premiums but
we're not insuring it anymore and we
said why and they said oh it's
structurally unsound so we said oh yeah
we'll be back in a year and we'll talk
about it and we did a lot of this work
to find out that actually the structure
hadn't really changed since 1954 when it
was made but what we did also see is we
could pop out little precipitates of
manganese sulfide so there's always
sulfur and iron and sulfur tends to be a
bad actor when it comes to material
properties you throw manganese into iron
to scoop up that sulfur in the form of
these little precipitates or inclusions
which were able to see perfectly when we
did an x-ray map just like the one we
did after the first exam it's like we
were looking at chris's copper silver
alloy mapping out where's the copper and
silver
I made this image the same way mapping
out where is there iron manganese and
sulfur that's how you can tell what it
is
and so dislocations and defects can
actually interact let's say this is the
interaction of a 1d defect a dislocation
with a 3d defect avoid if you have a
material that's deforming plastically
very smoothly and isn't going to undergo
fracture you want the dislocations to be
able to move if you put anything in
their way they tend to get stuck it's
not easy for that dislocation to shear
through a whole bunch of extra atoms and
in some cases you can stop the flood
that motion and favor fracture over slip
so anytime you make slip harder it means
that you're making fracture more likely
didn't say you're making it easier but
you're making it more likely and you
would prefer for materials to deform a
little bit by a slip then just break by
fracture so I think now's a good point
to go over a few key material properties
all of these are sometimes used to
describe the same thing in colloquial
speech that is wrong does anyone hear
that anyone here thought that lets say
stiffness or toughness or strength meant
the same thing
no okay got a few people it's okay
because it's used wrong all the time in
colloquial speech these actually refer
to different material properties with
different units and we're gonna go into
a little bit about what they are and
then show you a few videos to test your
intuition about the differences between
them so first I want to mention what
you're seeing right here is called a
stress-strain curve stress is simple
stress is just a force divided by an
area and usually the criterion for wheel
and material deform or will it break is
does it reach a certain stress it
doesn't matter just how much force you
put on it but it's like how much force
per atom or how much force per area
determines whether bonds are gonna break
and so on the y axis is stress let's say
the amount of force per area we're
putting in and strain is the amount of
deformation so that's stress and strain
is let's say the change in length over
the original length of some material in
what's called the engineering or
simplified notation and so something
that is stiff means you can put a lot of
force into it but it won't deform very
much that's kind of the easiest property
to understand is something that's very
stiff will have what's called a high
Young's modulus or a high slope right
here something that's super stiff like a
ceramic you can really push on it quite
a bit but you won't get it to deform
like you would this metal so the
opposite of stiff I would call compliant
not soft this is one of those tricky
things right there something that stiff
you try and flex it and it won't flex
something that's compliant you put a
little bit of force into it and it
undergoes some amount of strain and that
slope right there between the stress and
the strain we call the Youngs modulus we
also note that this part right here is
what's called the elastic region of
deformation by elastic we mean
reversible or it snaps right back so
right here when I bend this bar and it
snaps right back
that's called elastic
formation and it's reversible because
you can bend one way and it snaps right
back if I bent it more which I don't
want to do because this is a nice
zirconium fuel cladding rod you would
deform it irreversibly you to bend it
permanently and what the undergo what's
called plastic deformation when you
deviate from the slope and then a little
bit more stress can cause a lot more
deformation if any guys ever tried
pulling copper wire apart before that's
something I'd recommend you try for thin
wire so you don't cut your hands well
you may notice is that it's awfully hard
to get the copper deforming in the first
place but as soon as it starts to
stretch it gets really easy so this is
something I recommend go to the
electronics shop or wherever and try it
out on some really thin copper wire if
it's thick you'll slice through your
fingers and you don't want to do that
strength however that's a different and
that's a different metric where a
stiffness describes this slope here
strength describes the height or the
stress at which you start to plastically
deform they're in different units
stiffness is in stress over strain
whereas strength is given as a stress so
when you hear things like the yield
stress or the ultimate tensile stress
that's referring to how strong something
is which may have nothing to do with how
stiff it is toughness is another
property toughness is actually kind of
like the area under this curve because
if you do a force and apply it over a
distance that's like putting work into
the material and it ends up being a unit
of energy so toughness will tell you how
much energy you have to put into
something before creating a new free
surface otherwise known as fracture and
ductility is how much can you deform it
before it breaks so it would be like
this point right here on the strain axis
so I'll so give a little bit more
examples of what this is all about
toughness again is actually measured as
an energy required to form a free
surface or propagate a crack let's say
where as something that's ductile it
doesn't necessarily mean
it's tough like if you have a piece of
chewed chewing gum you can stretch it
quite a lot with very little energy and
then it's excu can say it's extremely
ductile but not very strong a piece of
copper wire you can also stretch at an
extremely far distance but it takes more
energy to do so so that's both ductile
and strong and then if you apply that
force over a certain distance stretching
out the wire you can also reveal some of
its toughness and how much energy it
takes to stretch that wire before it
breaks hardness is the last material
property I want to mention which is not
any of the ones that I showed on the
stress-strain curve hardness is the
resistance to a little bit of plastic
deformation so assuming that you're
already here how much more energy do you
have to put in to get the material to
deform plastically so very different
material properties all try and mention
all what they are so if we have a
stress-strain curve like so and it
follows the elastic region and then
deforms plastically this point what here
is what we call the yield strength
whatever that point on the stress axis
is this point right here our strain to
failure we can use as a measure of
ductility this slope right here refers
to the stiffness and finally this energy
right here is something like the
toughness and the hardness isn't quite
on this plot so I want to see if you
guys intuitively understand this because
the next lecture I'm going to be
throwing around the words like stiffness
toughness ductility hardness compliance
hard soft whatever and I want to make
sure that you just at least intuitively
understand so there's a few videos you
may have seen before anyone here watch
the hydraulic press Channel
there we go finally something that half
the class does we are going to predict
what's going to happen in each of these
cases based on these material properties
so in this case this is a compressor
eyes cylinder of co2 it's made of
aluminum
which is a very ductile material it's
also a very tough material what do you
how do you think it will deform when
smashed anyone ever tried this squishing
aluminum stuff what happens you compress
it and then what happens
will it fracture after a while okay if
you put a lot of energy into it
eventually when you reach this strain to
failure it should fracture but in your
personal hands-on experience does
aluminum tend to fracture when you bend
it a little bit
so then what words would you use to
describe it based on this curve right
here yep ductile I say yep ductile and
not brittle because you can bend it
quite a bit or stretch it quite a bit
before it fractures
how about stiffness is it really hard or
really easy to get aluminum bending it's
fairly easy so would you call that stiff
or compliant compliant okay what about
strength how hard is it to start
deforming aluminum irreversibly compared
to something like steel not very
especially pure aluminum you can almost
you can't you can chew through it if you
guys ever get a 1 yen coin from Japan
you can chew through it not very strong
and again you know your bite force is
also incredibly strong but anyway let's
see what actually happens when you
compress a rather ductile compliant and
not that strong aluminum canister is it
actually going oh it actually just get
the head that's what I wanted was there
sound
it was also pressurized with co2 but
notice what's left so actually watch in
slow-mo look how much you can compress
that even after the explosion no
fracture if you had done that with let's
say a glass canister what do you guys
think would have happened would have
shattered yeah we'll see that in a bit
with a material that may surprise you it
will fracture eventually but the
hydraulic press can't get it that far in
compression so that would be something
that's extremely ductile not that strong
cuz it wasn't that hard to deform
certainly we know it wasn't stronger
than the steel baseplate that they use
to do the Smashing because whatever's
the softer material is going to deform
more so here he's gonna have well I'll
let him describe it and then I'll let
you guess what's going to happen
you
what are you guys things gonna happen
we've got what looks like brass and
copper coins on a steel baseplate anyone
have any idea copy yeah everyone's
making this motion which means
everything's gonna flatten out right
let's find out
not nearly as much as you might have
expected
you
is anyone surprised by this what
happened there what actually happened
there was already described up here when
you get enough dislocations piling up
against each other during plastic
deformation you can undergo a process
called work hardening that process can
be physically described by a lot of
those dislocations piling up and making
it more and more difficult to continue
that deformation so what happened here
is the brass in the copper which started
out quite soft not that hard
quite ductile as you can see and not
that strong actually got stronger as
they were deformed interesting huh did
anyone expect this to happen okay
let's go to one that I think everyone
can guess what's gonna happen a lead
ball so has anyone ever tried playing
with lead before hopefully not I have
quite it ok good I'm not alone how would
you describe lead in terms of the
material properties here
yep it's not very stiff it doesn't take
much energy to start deforming it how
else
well is it hard or soft okay
you think it's ductile or brittle yeah
you think it's brittle so by that you
mean it's just gonna break apart right
if you deform it okay cool and would you
say is tough or not tough not a lot of
folks have hands-on experience with lead
it's probably good for your brains let's
find out
you
led pancake so what words would you use
to describe what just happened
ductile indeed I don't know what sort of
brittle led was it an alloy that you had
been playing with maybe uh-huh okay so
it was a sheet of lead that was easy to
snap so I would not call lead as a very
tough material because you didn't have
to put a lot of energy into it but did
it deform quite a bit before you snapped
it or did it just crumble apart okay so
in that case I would call it ductile
because it deformed a lot before
breaking but I would not call it tough
because it took very little energy to
get it to that breaking point and it
wasn't that stiff because it was quite
easy to get it let's say it's the amount
of energy what it's the amount of stress
you put in versus the strain could be
quite low and it would not be very
strong because it didn't take a lot of
energy or stress to get it moving let's
look at another ball in this case a
steel ball bearing what do you guys
think is gonna happen here
it's gonna shatter so you're guessing
that the steel is brittle right what
else
probably stiff quite stiff and strong
yeah I think so too but I don't think
the guy that did this expected that
you
let's surprise anybody
you
yeah quite a surprise right so in this
case materials like hardened steel
aren't necessarily that brittle in fact
you wouldn't want a ball bearing to be
brittle if you get a some small chip in
it or a little bit of grit or sand and
the bearings you would shot are the ball
bearing and cause instantaneous failure
of the rotating component so what you
actually want out of a high-strength
ball bearing is something that's
extremely hard resists deformation so it
doesn't undergo let's say change of
shape that would prevent it from rolling
without friction or with very little
friction you want it to be quite stiff
because you don't want the load of
whatever you're loading onto it to
deform it but you also don't want it to
be brittle so it's got to be somewhat
tough and ductile to prevent sudden
failure you'd rather it compress a tiny
bit than just cracking in half so you
can make things like ceramic ball
bearings which are very brittle very
stiff not that tough but also very
strong and you just have to make sure
that whatever part you make is not going
to reach any sort of yield strength
criterion or crack or anything now the
last one that's probably the most
surprising they bought a $4,000 diamond
it's a diamond like that big what do you
know about diamonds as a material in
terms of these properties yep both is
right they're extremely stiff it's the
hardest material that we know of almost
we've made slightly harder ones
artificially it's the hardest natural
material we know of what else do you
know whether they're strong or tough
they're not tough why do you say that
and have you seen the video oh wow
okay what else do we have yeah so you're
saying it's not tough you can cut
diamonds with other diamonds so the
cutting action usually depends on the
hardness of the relative hardness of the
material so if you want to polish or cut
something abrasively you need to use a
harder material because then the grit
itself won't wear away before the
material it's trying to cut but what's
going to happen here is we're gonna put
a diamond and try compressing it and
we'll see what its stress-strain curve
looks like so votes are what's gonna
happen who says like Monica it's gonna
shatter who think it's gonna break the
tools who think it's going to deform
plastically yeah I've never seen a
diamond deform plastically
you
oh yeah I could probably still sell
those absolutely no deformation it just
rotates and explodes yeah this would be
a material that we would have say has
almost zero ductility despite being
extremely hard I don't know if there
would even been enough deformation to
have a slight dent in the tool itself
there's probably a little hole where the
point of the diamond poked in but once
there was enough stress on that diamond
its stress-strain curve would look
something like that maybe like that you
yeah so it's important that you
intuitively understand the differences
between strength ductility hardness
toughness and stiffness because then
next class we can explain how radiation
changes them so any questions on the
materials and properties from today yeah
mm-hmm so the reason something would be
ductile versus brittle is whether or not
you can plastically deform it and that
means whether or not it's more
energetically favorable for dislocations
to keep moving versus just breaking a
plane of atoms in any irregular
direction and causing fracture so again
ductile ductility versus embrittlement
is that is the interplay between slip
and fracture slip it's normally done by
dislocation movement any defects created
by anything especially radiation damage
will make slip harder so that any
continued energy you put in will not
move dislocations but move towards
fracture so there's no other questions
we'll look at the stress-strain curves
of some other familiar materials anyway
it is ten o'clock in case you guys have
to go to other classes
yes if you guys have things for nuclear
activation analysis handed in do you
guys bring stuff in we're running out of
opportunities to do this all right in
that case entry for the quiz and with
the entry fee for the quiz will be your
nuclear activation analysis sample
you